welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition and this
episode we're breaking down the second
entry of lovecraft country
there's a lot to talk about and i just
want to get straight into it but
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here
in regards to the episode and some
elements of the book
if you enjoyed the video then please
drop a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day
anyway with that other way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
lovecraft country
okay so episode two titled whitey's on
the moon refers to a spoken word poem by
gil scott herron
which appears in the episode at one
point this poem criticized the apollo 11
space mission program
and the money that was spent on it it
stayed that the us government were happy
pouring billions into putting a white
man on the moon
whilst people on earth namely the black
community starved and were neglected
this idea of the connection between
poverty and capitalism
is exemplified early on in the episode
in the introduction
which picks up almost immediately after
the ending of the first entry
here we see letty and george dancing to
move on up
there's a positive vibe to the entire
thing but it's merely a distraction to
keep the pair subdued
whilst the mansion owners aka the order
of ancient dawn
enact their plan in the book they were
called the order of adam
and though it's switched up here they
still worship the so-called first man
now juxtaposing letty and george's
happiness atticus
cannot quite settle and after all the
things that he's encountered thus far
he's realized that there are often
things beneath the surface that aren't
immediately apparent
this was of course exemplified in the
diner last week but here
it goes far far beyond that letty's
clothes fit perfectly
and george has all of the books that he
loves at his disposal
neither pair remembers the horror of the
woods the previous night
and to me this symbolizes how
materialistic distractions and promises
of a better life
are often used by politicians to
persuade people into becoming apathetic
to the truth of what's really going on
memories can easily be manipulated and
things forgotten
with distractions and here we see it in
full effect
the episode is laced with the idea of
memories being twisted
and we'll get into this further in the
video now atticus
is the only one who can sense something
isn't right and
the bright white butler or rather ally
william arrives to give them a tour now
last week
i said that i thought this was caleb
however it looks like the show has done
a gender swap on the character
and the role will be filled by christina
breithwight
it looks like they're changing certain
things from the source material
whilst keeping others the same namely
this chapter
and parts of its eventual outcome now
both christina and william are aryans
which of course is a symbol of white
supremacy and we discover that they're
high-ranking members of an order of
wizards that date back centuries
this was created by titus braithwight as
was autumn itself
atticus is directly descended from him
and this is why the group have sought
the character
now when i say titus created autumn
itself
what i really mean is that he used
slaves to build it
and profited off their misery titus is
told to have made his fortune through
shipping
aka the slave trade and letty correcting
it here
shows how language is often used to
twist the past to fit a certain
narrative
and make people well forget he's said to
have been
awfully kind and though this is said in
a positive way
it actually means something very
negative if you're awful to someone
well you're awful so the phrase awfully
kind
hints as to how titus really was we
learned that the lodge that titus built
burned to the ground during an equinox
which is an event in which the sun
presides directly over the equator
there was only one survivor of this
blade which was atticus's ancestor
hannah whom titus had a baby with this
is viewed as an adam and eve situation
for their order
and with atticus being a direct
descendant it makes him of high value to
them
we learned that titus actually forced
himself on hannah and that she
escaped with her child during the blaze
this is centered at
as we see throughout the mansion that
there's this picture of a distressed eve
and adam with a snake as is his junk
which i can't show because of youtube
but it's definitely there the trio are
distracted with a luxurious lunch
and george realizes that they're being
watched they find their car completely
restored
and william sneakily appears out of
nowhere from here they travel to the cgi
village of autumn
in search of montrose we see that letty
and george actually suspect that atticus
is making it up
and this again shows how high-ranking
officials can often twist the narrative
and make people question those around
them rather than those in power
when they're about to get to the bottom
of it they hear the whistle from the
prior knight
which called up the shogoths i i did get
a lot of comments last week about how
they weren't actually shoghouts look
i know i know they don't typically look
like that it's just how they've been
redesigned for the show
velociraptors on six foot tall either so
i think they just changed it up and
called it the shogoth
as they do this a lot in tv and movies
anyway moving on they trace the sound to
a woman named dell
who acts as the sheriff for the village
similar to a lot of the characters
they've met along the way
the subtext of her words carry a lot of
hidden meaning to them
well i say that she she's clearly
telling them that she doesn't like black
people
but disguising it as her hatred for
black bears
now george surmises that as dell's tower
is the only stone building in the
village
that it's actually its prison and that
this is where montrose is being held
in the woods george recalls atticus's
past once more
and they're attacked by the same
monsters as the night before
however at this time they're saved by
christina and we see that george and
leddy's memory of the event
quickly begins to fade we learn that the
whistle has a connection to this too
and just in the way that it's able to
distract the monsters
it can also distract humans and make
them forget the only person it doesn't
work on is atticus
and he's taken to a lab which is where
he meets samuel
samuel is being operated on without
anesthetic and he has his organ removed
as part of a ritual
he goes off on a monologue about how he
wishes to restore the world to
the time of the garden of eden as back
then everything had its place
and rather than viewing things as being
equal he sees things
as needing a hierarchy christina tries
to persuade atticus that she's one of
the good ones
and also states that the group don't
work with the clan because they view
them as being too poor
again this use of language lets us know
that it's not because of their beliefs
but rather because of their wealth
christina lifts the spell on george and
leti
and we hear them screaming aware of the
horrors that they've seen
she then goes to deliver a monster and
it really speaks to these characters
psychology in the fact that they won't
mix with black people
but are happy to hang around with
monsters and care for them yeah
very very messed up group in la e's room
we see atticus comfort her
but this is shown to be a hallucination
and he reveals his junk which
is a snake similar to the adam and eve
painting in atticus's room he's
confronted by jia
who appears in the form of a korean
soldier you may remember last week that
atticus saw her in a vision at the start
of the episode
before talking to her on the phone it is
possible that he murdered her in korea
and though we don't know exactly what's
going on at the moment
clearly something's tying these two
characters together george sees
atticus's mother thora
and the pair dance together they recall
their time in tulsa
and we learned that they fled because of
the 1921 massacre
this recently picked up a lot of
attention because of the hbo show
watchmen
which depicted the events because of the
source material the show did start to
bring supernatural elements in
however this was a very real and
horrifying event
that shouldn't be glossed over and it's
clearly something that still haunts
george to this day
it's clear that george and his
sister-in-law were more than just
friends
and it is possible that george is
actually atticus's father
george steps away from the fantasy
realizing that he shouldn't be giving
into it
and atticus seemingly kills gr we
realize that the order is actually
looking over them
almost like animals in a zoo and the
trio are set free with the sounding of
the dinner bell
the order have been brought together for
a ceremony and williams states that it's
men only
further showcasing the group's view on
equality because of the sexism that
exists
christina has also been unable to join
the order and this hints towards her
actions
later in the episode i can also see this
being the reason why they gender swapped
the character
and in my opinion you know it works
quite well i'm not often a fan of when
they just change things up for the sake
of it
but here it's brought into the story and
i think that it definitely complements
the work
now atticus and george travel to the
dinner and we see the looks that the
order give them
throughout the show so far there have
been several looks given to atticus to
highlight how people really feel about
him
i think this motif of someone looking at
someone in an almost disgusted way
also highlights their views eyes
looks views i don't know if i'm reaching
there but yeah
that's how i see it all tying together
william gives lip service to them not
wanting atticus or george there
and samuel steps forward in robes
similar to titus
we see that the organ that he had taken
from his body before is now being served
up as food
and this is meant to represent how he's
willing to give up a part of himself for
others like adam
george interrupts the ceremony and gives
a speech about secret societies
and i absolutely love this moment now he
just completely commands the dinner
and also discusses how secret societies
are of course exclusive
and not inclusive and there's also lip
service given to prince hall
prince hall was not allowed into the
freemasons because of the colour of his
skin
however in this order there is a
loophole in that men who are direct
descendants of the leader
are automatically included and can also
give orders
these sons of sons aka atticus are
allowed to do what they want
and atticus orders everyone except
samuel out
and it's great watching them having to
begrudgingly accept it
atticus orders samuel to return his
father and he stands up
and drops another monologue samuel calls
him diluted
and it's hinted that though atticus is
unable to remember the pain that hannah
actually ended up enduring
it's still there beneath the surface
this of course ties back to the theme of
memories which is late throughout the
episode
and i love how this motif is repeated at
several points
they go to the prison and find
montrose's canteen and dell
arrives however letty knocks her out and
we discover that montrose was tunneling
his way out as they arrived at the tower
it's not the nicest family reunion and
here the seeds are sown that
no matter what montrose may never like
his son
we discovered the letter was also sent
by the sons to lure atticus out there
the group tried to escape in the silver
bentley that christina drove last week
but it doesn't go to plan now this car
ride is very interesting as
we learn that the order have specific
books in which they pull from
which will grant them access to the
garden of eden in order to give them
immortality
there's also lip service paid to the
necronomicon which
i believe that let he takes at the end
there is a story later in the book which
looks like it's going to be next episode
which involves her and the dead so i
think it being dropped here
has some significance now before they're
able to make it over the bridge
a barrier stops them and this is similar
to the one that christina used last week
to flip the car
also shout out to marilyn manson i
remember that song
that's used here being houston john wick
and it works just as well
now samuel shoots and kills letty which
then forces atticus to be part of their
plan
it turns out that atticus will be using
a ritual in order to channel the sun
and open a portal to the garden of eden
which in turn will give the order
immortality
now what i think this reveal is playing
upon is the fact that predominantly in
fiction
there exists a stereotype of the magical
negro
this is something that has littered a
lot of stories and throughout the
decades there have been several films
and books that have used the trope that
a magical black character
should be in place to basically
sacrifice themselves to empower the
white characters
this trope was first really brought to
the forefront of discussion by spike lee
during a speech in 2001 at yale
university
lee stated that it basically defined
black people to being useful for one
thing
and nothing really beyond that stephen
king was criticized for adopting this
a lot in his early work including the
shining and of course the green mile
but it goes far beyond these examples
the trope typically defines the
character in a subservient role
such as a janitor or prisoner and they
were unable to use their powers for
themselves
purely being in place to better others
this was a trope created by white people
in order to create segregation even in
works of art
though laced in the subtext it does
convey the message that black characters
only exist to further the white
character's goal
you very much get the feeling that the
suns here exemplify this
and that they believe themselves better
than atticus even though atticus
descends directly from the person that
they worship
now i love the way that their arrogance
and disregard for atticus is what
blindsides them
and lovecraft country does an excellent
job of taking this trope
flipping it on its head and having
atticus survive whilst the group perish
we'll get into that later though and
atticus finds that samuel actually
revived letty
but that george is still wounded
together atticus and christina discussed
their shared dislike for their fathers
and mirroring this montrose and george
go over how the former hated their dad
george also reveals how atticus may not
even be montrose's son
and this further hammers home the idea
that george and thora had something
going on
atticus is taken to the ceremony whilst
whitey on the moon plays
and its use here shows that atticus is
having to basically be forced into pain
whilst white people around him can
achieve immortality
the portal to eden opens and atticus
sees hannah in the doorway
he realizes that like she did he must
escape the ritual
and the people who wish for nothing more
than to use him until he has no further
use
it becomes clear that hannah was used in
the original ceremony
and this is the reason for the
destruction of the lodge atticus's power
rips through the mansion
and it begins to bring it all crashing
down samuel is petrified
and destroyed and it all ends in a big
blaze of glory
unfortunately we learn that george
succumbed to his wounds
which leaves letty atticus and montrose
on their own
now this differs from the book quite a
lot as george survived
in that and it's quite a devastating
death that i think atticus will blame
himself for
he was told that if he took part in the
ritual that samuel would heal him
but as he didn't he now can't the
necronomicom
is likely what was used to revive letty
and who knows it might even be used to
bring george back to life to to bring
things more in line with the book
i kind of don't think that theory will
happen but yeah there's a lot of things
to consider
it's a big way to end the episode and
yeah what a tough watch
now that pretty much concludes his arc
and ends the first real section of the
book
i will be discussing the upcoming
chapter so if you don't want anything
ruined
then it's time to dive out the video if
you're still here
then going forward it looks like we're
picking up in the next story which
centers around
getting a large inheritance with her
sister she buys a mansion that's very
cheap
and it seems too good to be true it
turns out that it is
and it's actually haunted the white
neighbors in the area also hate that she
and her sister have moved in
and that he comes face to face with the
ghosts that live there which i think
ties into the mention of the
necronomicon
lee of course died and came back to life
and i think the afterlife will be used
heavily in the next episode when she
comes to terms with the ghosts
anyway that's the episodes and preview
and
yeah also i forgot to mention christina
will be back but i don't want to ruin
what happens just yet now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the entry
so make sure you comment below and let
me know i think last time there were
some much needed corrections on things i
said and interpreted wrongly
and i really appreciate people taking
the time to write them i'm trying to
educate myself on this stuff
quite a lot and it definitely helps the
videos going forward as i do read all
the comments and try to respond to as
many as i can
now if you want to see our breakdown
from last week then make sure you check
it out after this
and don't forget we're giving away a
free copy of the avengers on any console
of your choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of august so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on a discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of this long
long breakdown
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you